THEIR CHILDREN'S LIVES AS MORE
THAN 700,000 AMERICANS HAVE DIED
IN THIS PANDEMIC.
AND LET'S NOT FORGET THE ANGER
THAT EXPLODED INTO ONE OF THE
DARKEST DAYS IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
BLOODTHIRSTY RIOTERS ATTACKING
THE SEAT OF OUR DEMOCRACY ON
JANUARY 6th.
LET'S NOT FORGET THEY TRIED TO
OVERTURN A FREE AND FAIR
ELECTION.
AND LET'S NOT FORGET THE RIOTERS
PUT UP A GALLOWS OUTSIDE AND
CHANTED "HANG MIKE PENCE."
>> HANG MIKE PENCE!
HANG MIKE PENCE!
>> LET'S NOT FORGET THAT THEN
VICE PRESIDENT AND HIS FAMILY
HAD TO RUN FOR THEIR LIVES.
DON'T BELIEVE ME?
LOOK.
THERE'S THE VIDEO RIGHT THERE.
WE CAN NEVER FORGET WHAT WE SAW.
BUT APPARENTLY MIKE PENCE HAS
FORGOTTEN ALL ABOUT IT.
IMAGINE THAT.
I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO HIM
RESORTING TO PAGE 1 IN THE TRUMP
PLAYBOOK, BLAME THE MEDIA.
REALLY HE'S TRYING TO BLAME THE
MEDIA.
TRYING TO BLAME THE MEDIA FOR
THE ATTACK BY VIOLENT RIOTERS.
TRUMP SUPPORTERS.
AN ATTACK THAT FORCED HIM TO RUN
FOR HIS LIFE WITH HIS FAMILY.
>> I KNOW THE MEDIA WANTS TO
DISTRACT FROM THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION'S FAILED AGENDA
BY FOCUSING ON ONE DAY IN
JANUARY.
THEY WANT TO USE THAT ONE DAY TO
TRY AND DEMEAN THE CHARACTER AND
INTENTIONS OF 74 MILLION
AMERICANS WHO BELIEVED WE COULD
BE STRONG AGAIN AND PROSPEROUS
AGAIN AND SUPPORTED OUR
ADMINISTRATION IN 2016 AND 2020.
>> GOOGLE STOCKHOLM SYNDROME.
TRYING TO GET ON THE GOOD SIDE
OF THE MAN WHO STOOD BY AND DID
NOTHING WHILE PENCE'S LIFE WAS
LITERALLY IN DANGER, ALL BECAUSE
HE DID HIS JOB INSTEAD OF TRYING
TO OVERTURN THE ELECTION AS HIS
BOSS WANTED HIM TO DO.
AND WHAT HAPPENED ON JANUARY
6th?
NOT JUST ABOUT ONE DAY.
IT'S ABOUT THE VERY REAL THREAT
TO OUR DEMOCRACY.
THE ANGER.
THE MISINFORMATION.
STILL OUT THERE.
THE BIG LIE OF NON-EXISTENT
ELECTION FRAUD STILL OUT THERE.
LAYING THE GROUNDWORK FOR THE
NEXT TIME.
BUT FAR TOO MANY REPUBLICANS ARE
PUTTING THEIR POLITICAL LIVES
AHEAD OF THE DEFENSE OF OUR
DEMOCRACY.
NIKKI HALEY.
OKAY?
NIKKI HALEY TELLING THE "WALL
STREET JOURNAL" THE FORMER
PRESIDENT IS A FRIEND AND SAYING
SHE'S CONSULT WITH HIM BEFORE
THROWING HER HAT INTO THE RING
FOR A WHITE HOUSE RUN.
UM.
I FEEL LIKE I KNOW HOW THAT
CONVERSATION WOULD GO.
AND I PROBABLY CAN'T REPEAT THE
EXACT WORDS THAT HE MIGHT USE.
REMEMBER WHEN SHE SAID THAT SHE
WAS DISGUSTED BY HIS TREATMENT
OF MIKE PENCE, DISGUSTED?
REMEMBER WHEN SHE SAID THAT SHE
DIDN'T THINK THE FORMER
PRESIDENT WAS GOING TO BE IN THE
PICTURE ANYMORE?
NOW SHE SAYS THEY NEED HIM IN
THE GOP.
THE LAST THING THEY NEED.
AND THEN THERE IS FORMER TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
STEPHANIE GRISHAM.
YOU KNOW, THE ONE WHO NEVER HELD
A PRESS BRIEFING, WHICH WAS HER
JOB.
NOW SHE IS WARNING IF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT WERE TO WIN A SECOND
TERM HE WOULD SURROUND HIMSELF
WITH THE JANUARY 6th CROWD.
>> I HAVE SAID PEOPLE SUCH AS
SIDNEY POWELL OR RUDY GIULIANI
OR SOME OF THE PEOPLE WHO
BELIEVE WHOLEHEARTEDLY IN THESE
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, I BELIEVE
THAT IF HE WERE TO WIN IN 2024
HE WILL PICK WHOEVER STOOD BY
HIM, YOU KNOW, DEFENDED HIM, AND
HE WILL PLACE THOSE PEOPLE WHO
WILL HAVE DEFENDED THE
INDEFENSIBLE INTO THE WHITE
HOUSE.
>> OKAY.
THERE'S SO MUCH I WANT TO SAY.
WHERE WERE THESE PEOPLE WHEN IT
WAS HAPPENING?
WHEN THEY WERE -- JUST HOLD THE
PROMPTER.
WHERE WERE THESE PEOPLE?
WHEN THEY WERE -- WHERE WAS THIS
ATTITUDE WHEN THEY WERE ON FOX
NEWS SAYING THE MOST INSANE --
THE MOST INSANE STUFF, DEFENDING
THE MOST INSANE BEHAVIOR TALKING
CRAP ABOUT CNN AND THE FAKE
NEWS, NOT HOLDING PRESS
CONFERENCES, MAKING EXCUSES FOR
EVERYTHING THAT TRUMP DID,
PLAYING CLEANUP ON AISLE 45.
EVERY DAY.
NOW THEY WANT TO COME ON CNN.
WHY DO YOU WANT TO COME ON CNN
TO SELL A BOOK WHEN ALL YOU DID
WAS TALK CRAP ABOUT CNN?
HUH?
OR ANY OTHER NETWORK.
GO ON THE FOX PROPAGANDA NETWORK
AND SELL YOUR BOOK.
WHY DIDN'T YOU STAND UP FOR OUR
DEMOCRACY WHEN YOU HAD THE
CHANCE TO DO IT?
WHEN IT MATTERED.
BEFORE THERE WAS A JANUARY 6th.
BECAUSE YOU SAW IT COMING.
STEPHANIE GRISHAM, THE FACT IS
SHE SAW PLENTY WHEN SHE WAS IN
THE WHITE HOUSE HERSELF.
SHE COULD HAVE WARNED AMERICA
THEN.
SHE DIDN'T DO IT.
NOW SHE'S RUNNING TO JAKE
TAPPER, TALKING ABOUT THE THEN
PRESIDENT WAS TRYING TO STAGE A
COUP?
NO CRAP.
>> YOU THINK THE PRESIDENT WAS
ESSENTIALLY TRYING TO STAGE A
COUP?
>> I DO.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT HE WAS
DOING TO VICE PRESIDENT PENCE,
WHEN YOU LOOK AT HOW MANY WAYS
HE WAS TRYING TO GET PEOPLE, IN
PHONE CALLS EVEN WITH GEORGIA
AND ARIZONA AND THEN AGAIN WITH
PRESSURING MIKE PENCE WITH ALL
HE WANTED TO DO AND IN THAT MEMO
THAT HAS NOW COME OUT ABOUT ALL
THE WAYS TO OVERTURN THIS
ELECTION, I DO.
IT'S DANGEROUS.
>> YEAH, IT'S DANGEROUS.
YOU COULD HAVE DONE THAT WHEN
YOU WERE THE PRESS SECRETARY.
AND A DISGRACED TWICE IMPEACHED
ONE-TERM FORMER PRESIDENT
PLOTTING TO GET BACK INTO THE
WHITE HOUSE IS ABSOLUTELY A
THREAT TO OUR DEMOCRACY.
MEANWHILE, THE DULY ELECTED
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
IS TAKING HIS CASE TO AMERICA AS
HIS AGENDA HANGS IN THE BALANCE.
>> THESE BILLS ARE NOT ABOUT
LEFT VERSUS RIGHT OR MODERATE
VERSUS PROGRESSIVE OR ANYTHING
THAT PITS AMERICANS AGAINST ONE
ANOTHER.
THESE BILLS ARE ABOUT
COMPETITIVENESS VERSUS
COMPLACENCY.
THEY'RE ABOUT OPPORTUNITY VERSUS
DECAY.
THEY'RE ABOUT LEADING THE WORLD
OR CONTINUING TO LET THE WORLD
PASS US BY, WHICH IS LITERALLY
HAPPENING.
>> AND CONSIDERING THE NUCLEAR
OPTION, A CARVE-OUT OF THE
FILIBUSTER TO RAISE THE DEBT
CEILING BY OCTOBER 18th.
>> ARE DEMOCRATS CONSIDERING
USING THE NUCLEAR OPTION, TO
RAISE THE DEBT LIMIT, USING A
CARVE-OUT WITH THE FILIBUSTER TO
RAISE THE DEBT LIMIT?
>> OH, I THINK THAT'S A REAL
POSSIBILITY.
>> SO IF YOU THINK THE DEBT
CEILING DOESN'T MATTER TO YOU,
OKAY?
IF YOU'RE THINKING -- I WANT YOU
TO REALLY THINK ABOUT THIS.
OKAY?
BECAUSE THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
AFFECTS EVERY SINGLE AMERICAN.
NOT JUST IN THE LONG TERM.
NOT JUST IN THE SHORT TERM BUT
IN THE LONG TERM.
OKAY?
SO THINK ABOUT THIS.
WHAT IF YOU DON'T GET YOUR
SOCIAL SECURITY PAYMENT ON TIME?
WHAT IF IT REALLY AFFECTS YOUR
401(k) AND IT GETS HAMMERED?
WHAT IF MORTGAGE RATES SKYROCKET
AND YOU CAN'T AFFORD A HOUSE?
WHAT IF YOU LOSE YOUR JOB?
THAT IS WHAT COULD HAPPEN IF
REPUBLICANS REFUSE TO DO THEIR
JOBS.
THAT'S HOW TOXIC OUR POLITICS
HAVE BECOME.
SO THE TELL-ALL PEOPLE WHO
WORKED FOR THE ADMINISTRATION,
YOU COULD HAVE HEADED TH